[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est à Hawaï et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait Hawaï alors on vient se
baigner oui et pas que on vient surtout
voir ça ça ce sont stad dragon stade
dragon c'est une marque appartient à
quoi comme et Snapdragon on va venir
voir ici les nouveaux processeurs pour
Android pour l'année 2023 chaque année à
la même période quelque chose près et
bien quoi comme bien présenté ses
nouveaux processeurs qui sortiront
l'année prochaine sur les smartphones
Android très haut de gamme donc ce qu'on
vient voir aujourd'hui et bien ce sont
les nouveaux processeurs de Qualcomm
c'est un dragon 8 gène 2 8 de deuxième
génération on avait la première
génération dernière on s'en doutera donc
faut faire le portrait-robot de ce
nouveau processeur on va regarder
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire vous
allez voir il y a plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités en plus de ça quoi comme
infrastru truc super dingue c'est qu'ils
ont fait des partenariats avec Sony avec
Samsung pour la première fois avec un
chien omi et ça donne un résultat qui
est super intéressant et que j'attends
vraiment avec impatience pour voir ce
que vont nous développer tous les
constructeurs avec cette nouvelle puce
en 2023 vous allez voir vous allez voir
accrocher vous parce que franchement ça
va déchirer
[Musique]
alors comme j'aimais bien le faire une
époque on va se refaire un petit tour de
la pièce et le petit tour de la chambre
histoire de vous emmener avec moi un peu
en immersion je vous cache pas que quoi
comme nougat avec des très très grandes
pioles on est vachement bien ici alors
très rapidement venez voir parce que
tout qui est quand même très cool ici le
clou du spectacle alors c'est toujours
pas ici c'est par là c'est toujours pas
là c'est juste là c'est une énorme salle
de bain énorme salle de bain qui est
très cool avec regardez on a ici une
grande douche et une énorme baignoire
autant vous dire que c'est marrant alors
j'ai pas faire doucher baignoire en même
temps mais c'est bien on est bien on est
heureux on est Hawaii on est aujourd'hui
le 16 novembre 2022 il fait super beau
on est en T-shirt et presque en short ça
c'est plutôt rare et ça c'est très cool
allez on va commencer l'enregistrement
ici sur la plage comme ça je vous donne
un peu de chaleur je donne un peu
d'amour je vous permets de vous
rafraîchir de vous rafraîchez pas
comment il fait chaud ici on est très
très bien on se parle aujourd'hui du
Snapdragon 8 Jen 2 et ce gène de
pourquoi est-ce qu'il est intéressant et
bien c'est très galère il y a un truc à
bout de bois comme ça regardez hop là
hop voilà pourquoi se dire 2 il est
intéressant et bien parce que quoi comme
a fait un très gros focus sur
l'intelligence artificielle ici pour
venir maximiser l'expérience bon alors
et cette fille elle va servir à quoi
elle va servir pour différentes choses
elle va servir pour la 5G pour
l'autonomie pour la performance pour la
partie photo vidéo également premier
exemple très simple il y a eu une
fonctionnalité qui a été montrée qui a
été développée en partenariat avec
Xiaomi qui permet de faire de la
traduction instantanée dans plusieurs
langues ce qui veut dire que vous êtes
en train de parler vous allez voir la
traduction instantanée qui peut se faire
sur le coller notamment avec les pixels
ont déjà vu Google le fait ça marche
très bien sauf que là vous allez avoir
dans plusieurs langues alors on me direz
c'est quoi l'usage peut-être que tout de
suite au delà de côté traduction
effectivement en plus côté un peu
professionnel et business on le voit pas
directement mais c'est un truc qui peut
être intéressant et on voit ici derrière
que vous avez le lien et en plus qui est
très cool et je vous le disais tout à
l'heure c'est le fait que Qualcomm
travail avec d'autres marques et ici
notamment Xiaomi pour trouver des
synergies et développer de nouvelles
fonctionnalités
[Musique]
autre exemple de fonctionnalités que est
venu mettre ici en place c'est lorsque
vous regardez votre téléphone vous
l'avez sous les yeux comme ça et bien
vous avez une pause qui va se mettre
automatiquement lorsque vous partez par
exemple vous avez une vidéo qui en
lecture je sais rien vous êtes comme ça
avec votre téléphone tac tac et une
vidéo qui est bien et bien vous ça sonne
à la porte vous devez vous lever vous
partez et bien votre smartphone au
travers de la caméra voit que vous
n'êtes plus en train de le regarder il
fait quoi il met la pause et lorsque
vous revenez que vous reposez vos yeux
dessus et bien il reprend la lecture une
fois de plus une fonctionnalité qui est
là avec de l'intelligence artificielle
et qui permet de maximiser l'expérience
utilisateur bon alors tout ça c'est bien
mais quand est-il en terme de
performance parce que c'est vraiment ce
qui va nous intéresser pour une puce ici
alors par rapport à la génération
précédente qui est sortie l'année
dernière la star dragon 8 gène 1 et bien
on a quatre fois plus de performances
alors le truc qui est intéressant c'est
que on reste avec la même finesse de
gravure en 4 nanomètres on n'est pas
descendu ici en 3 nanomètres exactement
sur la même chose et ici c'est une puce
qui est gravée par TSMC tsnc c'est une
entreprise qui est à Taïwan faut savoir
que le syndragon 8 gène 1 avait été
gravé par Samsung et la version plus le
saint dragon 8 plus Jane 1 avait lui
était et par ta SMC là sur le sadragon 8
Jen 2 il commence directement avec tes
SNC
truc qui est intéressant ici vous avez
le dual 5 Gims active ça veut dire que
lorsque vous passez un coup de fil sur
votre première carte SIM la deuxième
carte SIM continue à fonctionner
également 5 g en gros on a 5G sur les
deux cartes SIM en même temps pourvu que
vos smartphones acceptent deux cartes
SIM bien évidemment c'est pas forcément
le cas tous les smartphones mais si vous
avez deux tiroirs de cartes SIM 5g et
bien ils vont pouvoir fonctionner deux
concerts toutes les deux en 5G mais
surtout avec cette puce est la première
fois qu'on va venir retrouver du wifi 7
avec des débits qui vont jusqu'à 5,8
Gigabits par seconde et une latence
inférieure à 2 millisecondes à savoir
que le wifi 16 sera deux fois plus
performant que le wifi 6
[Musique]
qu'en est-il au niveau du CPU c'est quoi
le code s'appelle le cRIO ici on sera
35% plus rapide par rapport à la
génération précédente et 40% plus
efficient au niveau de la conservation
énergétique avec un CPU à 3,19 GHz et là
quoi comme nous sort une première
mondiale accrochez-vous c'est super
intéressant c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
World force cognitive ISP donc ça
travaille au niveau de la partie photo
au niveau de la partie vidéo en gros ce
qui se passe et vous allez avoir de la
reconnaissance de scène au niveau de la
photo au niveau de la vidéo imaginez par
exemple ici là vous me voyez moi il va
venir reconnaître que moi je suis un
humain il va reconnaître que le bleu
c'est le ciel il va reconnaître la
plante il va tout reconnaître ou
délimiter zone par zone pour venir les
optimiser indépendamment les unes des
autres et ça en temps réel il va le
faire au niveau de la vidéo et le truc
est super intéressant parce que autant
on connaissait le HDR qu'on peut venir
retrouver à droite à gauche ok ça c'est
plutôt bien ça marche très très bien
mais au niveau de la vidéo ça permet
d'aller plus loin ils nous ont même fait
une démo vous voyez quelqu'un on allait
augmenter améliorer les teintes de peau
venir saturer un peu plus les lèvres
complètement optimisé le rendu de la
vidéo alors ils nous ont fait une démo
hein c'est un peu technique mais en fait
vous avez 8 couches d'image qui vont
venir traiter indépendamment par exemple
on voyait un chien on vient zoomer dans
l'oeil et on voit un reflet et bien ils
viennent corriger le reflet le reflet
automatiquement lorsqu'on prend une
photo par exemple comme ça et que vous
voyez il y a un petit bout de flou j'en
sais rien parce qu'il y a un bout de
lunettes la formation qui passe derrière
et bien elle est complètement corrigée
parce que vous avez l'IA qui comprend
derrière on aura plus de détails au
niveau des cheveux au niveau de la
matière on aura une eau un peu plus
turquoise de l'herbe encore plus verte
le truc est assez sympa ça c'est assez
malin parce que moi que ça pour un
maximiser le rendu qu'on va avoir au
niveau de nos smartphones que ce soit au
niveau de la photo que ce soit au niveau
de la vidéo donc on va voir de vraies
petites caméras qui vont venir supprimer
tous les petits problèmes qu'on va
pouvoir avoir à droite à gauche et ça
c'est super bien pour les créateurs de
contenu vous voyez typiquement parce que
on a pas forcément des caméras pas
forcément un gros boitier comme j'ai
tout de suite ici lorsque je suis en
train de tourner pour voir plutôt un
smartphone et avec votre smartphone et
bien vous allez avoir un outil très
simple un peu on the go que vous prenez
que vous emmener avec vous et derrière
la puissance de calcul va venir faire
tout le boulot pour vous
au niveau du maximum des capacités on
peut venir monter jusqu'en 8k HDR en 4K
slow motion en 16 bits
maximum de 200 mégapixels et pour
accepter également un capteur de 1 pouce
sans coprocesseur parce que 14 on l'a
déjà vu au niveau des smartphones mais
vous aviez un coprocesseur ici vous en
aurez pas parce que votre dragon 8 GN2
va faire le boulot directement il le
fera tout seul il a suffisamment de
ressources sur le capot donc on va qu'on
a beaucoup de performances ça c'est
chouette et d'ailleurs ici c'est la
première fois que Qualcomm monte un
partenariat avec Samsung première fois
que je le vois en tout cas au niveau des
capteurs de Samsung ils nous ont montré
un partenariat avec un capteur de
Samsung de 200 mégapixels je vous passe
la référence c'est un peu habitable on
s'en fiche ce qui nous intéresse et bien
voir qu'il cherche des partenaires forts
pour maximiser l'expérience ici vous
allez avoir une expérience qui va être
totalement optimisée pour l'autofocus le
HDR les photos en faible luminosité le
pixel binding c'est-à-dire prendre
plusieurs pixels ici vous en avez 200
donc 200 mégapixels vous prenez beaucoup
de pixels vous les combinez entre eux
pour faire des beaucoup plus gros pixels
et capter plus de lumière donc ça
revient effectivement à optimiser les
photos et les vidéos l'impression de
faible luminosité et la vidéo en 8k et
d'ailleurs il y a une annonce qui a été
faite qui est super supra intéressant
c'est peut-être l'annonce qu'il faut
retenir ici c'est le boss de Qualcomm a
dit ça le CIO Cristiano allemand alors
il l'a dit lors d'une interview c'est
une interview qui a donné aux Figaro
Elsa et il a dit à Elsa que sur les
prochains Samsung Galaxy S23 donc les
S23 on connaît pas encore le line-up
mais on probablement le S23 S23 plus et
le S23 ultra et bien tous les
smartphones dans le monde entier auront
un processeur de Qualcomm alors je sais
pas si vous le savez mais jusqu'à
présent vous aviez les États-Unis et le
Canada qui avait un Snapdragon et puis
pour le reste du monde on avait un
processeur exinos processeur et Xeno
c'est un processeur qui est fabriqué par
Samsung directement et là non ils vont
venir utiliser sur le monde entier sur
tous les S23 et bien un processeur de
Qualcomm le saint dragon 8 Jane II donc
ça c'est vraiment une très très grosse
information c'est super intéressant
parce que c'est un gros changement qui a
annoncé chez Samsung est-ce que Samsung
va continuer à fabriquer des exinos je
pense que oui pour autant est-ce qu'ils
vont le mettre sur d'autres modèles
allez savoir en tout cas l'année
prochaine sur les modèles les plus haut
de gamme de Samsung on ne retrouvera pas
un fournisseur exinos en Europe on
retrouvera gone un qualcool dans le
monde entier sur les Samsung Galaxy S23
mais en plus de ça sur les hedfold et
également les zip ça c'est une annonce
de dingue parce que Samsung n'a pas
encore pris la parole dessus et c'est le
boss de quoi comme Cristiano et mode qui
donne la formation et ça c'est assez
dingue ça c'est complètement dingue
autre partenariat fort également qu'ils
ont montré c'est avec deux capteurs de
Sony alors ça c'est super intéressant
également parce que c'est une autre
façon de concevoir le HDR je vous
explique l'histoire normalement le HDR
il se fait directement au niveau du
processeur c'est processeur qui va venir
mouliner pour vous sortir vous savez le
HDR en fait c'est que vous avez
différentes photos qui sont faites en
différentes expositions donc vous avez
un truc qui est très exposé un petit peu
moins un petit peu moins un petit peu
moins et à la fin carrément pas beaucoup
exposé on vient combiner tout ça pour
vous sortir les meilleures parties et
avoir le meilleur rendu possible en fait
vous avez pas juste une photo vous avez
plusieurs photos qui se combinent vous
avez derrière un truc qui vient calculer
et ça vous sort une super photo en HDR
ici le truc va être relativement
différent pourquoi parce que avec ces
deux capteurs de Sony et bien le HDR va
se faire déjà au niveau du capteur de
Sony c'est à dire que vous avez déjà 4
HDR qui se font c'est impossible au
niveau du capteur de Sony vous arrivez
déjà avec une image qui avant qu'elle
arrive au niveau du processeur en
sortant du capteur a déjà un traitement
HDR et en plus de ça vous avez votre
processeur le syndragon 8 gène 2 qui lui
va venir mouliner pour apporter une
couche de HDR en plus donc vous allez
avoir une image qui va être encore plus
optimisée ça ira surtout beaucoup plus
vite avec un rendu optimisé et très
rapidement et ça c'est chouette et c'est
une fois de plus cette vision business
qui est intéressante parce qu'ici
Qualcom est cherché des partenaires
forts pour optimiser l'image alors je
sais pas si vous êtes vraiment coutumier
ça probablement si vous regardez cette
vidéo mais vous savez probablement que
Sony est un acteur indispensable et
majeur au niveau des capteurs photos et
notamment sur les smartphones et cette
technologie Sony Qualcomm elle permet
quoi et bien d'avoir moins de bruit dans
les zones de faible luminosité ça
devient une fois de plus optimiser le
rendu pour vous
[Musique]
c'est quoi c'est le flou derrière plan
que vous allez avoir et lorsque vous
avez un feu arrière-plan vous avez des
petits points qui se dessine derrière en
gros votre caméra elle vient vous
détourez-vous et tout le reste en
arrière-plan est flou et lorsque vous
avez des petites lumières et bien les
petites lumières ça fait des petits
points et bah là ils ont fait un truc
qui est assez malin grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle une fois de
plus ils peuvent venir changer la forme
de ces petits points vous faire des
petits diamants vous faire des petits
cœurs j'ai vu la démo ça marche c'est
assez bluffant alors vous me direz quel
est l'usage est-ce que on va réellement
vouloir avoir des petits cœurs derrière
nous j'en sais fichement rien par contre
le truc qui est intéressant c'est que
ils peuvent le faire et puisqu'ils
peuvent le faire ils vous le montrent à
voir s'il est constructeurs vont venir à
l'intégrer plus tard mais eux ont la
technologie l'ont développé et le truc
est assez pertinent et intéressant donc
à voir si ça arrive à voir je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez dites-le moi juste
en bas dans les commentaires et une fois
de plus pour ça marrant parce que ça
montre la force de frappe ça monte
l'innovation ça monte tout le travail
qui font derrière pour s'afficher comme
étant le plus gros fabricant de
processeurs au monde au niveau des
smartphones ayant la plus grosse
capacité de calcul et je trouve ça
extrêmement bluffant
alors vous avez plein de trucs également
qui arrive au niveau de la vidéo vous
avez le pro sight vidéo capture avec 5
fois plus de bitrate plus de détails
moins de bruit on vient réduire les
artefacts enfin on comprend ici qu'en
fait on vient totalement améliorer la
qualité ici au niveau de la vidéo et
autre truc qui est marrant c'est
l'horizon leving alors je sais pas si
vous connaissez l'histoire on l'a vu au
niveau de la GoPro c'est à dire que je
monte sur GoPro sur GoPro vous avez
votre caméra et quand votre caméra elle
tourne comme ça et bien l'image reste
stable reste au centre en fait ça bouge
pas et on va pouvoir l'avoir également
sur les smartphones Android donc le truc
est super intéressant vous allez vous
retrouver avec votre smartphone qui
bouge comme ça on l'a déjà vu un peu
chez vivo parce que c'est une caméra
gimbol mais au-delà d'une caméra gimbal
votre smartphone va bouger comme ça et
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle et à
la capacité de calcul et bien votre
image ne bougera pas et ça croyez-moi
pour moi c'est juste génial
alors je vous parlais il y a quelques
instants d'une fonctionnalité qui est
intéressante au niveau de la caméra qui
fait que lorsque vous regardez votre
smartphone est bien sali et lorsque vous
le regardez plus que vous partez ça
arrête la lecture en fait il y a un truc
qui est marrant c'est ce qu'ils
appellent le always sensing caméra en
fait votre caméra elle va être toujours
être en train de vous regarder pour
différents usages le premier truc c'est
que si par exemple vous êtes en train de
lire un message hyper important que
quelqu'un vient derrière vous et en
train de lire au-dessus de votre épaule
et bien votre smartphone reconnaît
quelqu'un derrière vous et qui est en
train de regarder et Tac il arrête je
sais pas je pense qu'il a éteint il va
[ __ ] quoi on pourra pas venir lire et
dès que la personne parle plus le texte
s'affiche à nouveau donc je trouve ça
vachement bien alors il y a d'autres
trucs ils ont lancé qui sont très cool
au niveau de la caméra par exemple votre
téléphone est éteint vous le prenez et
il y a un QR code sur une table un
restaurant j'en sais fiche vraiment rien
il y a un QR code donc vous prenez votre
téléphone et vous ne l'allumez pas vous
le prenez vous le posez au-dessus il
reconnaît le QR code et il le scanne
automatiquement tout ça une fois de plus
grâce à de l'intelligence artificielle
qui va venir analyser en permanence ce
qui se passe entre fonctionnalité qui
est assez rigolote au niveau de votre
caméra de selfie lorsque vous êtes en
train de lire un texte et que d'un coup
vous êtes un peu naze vous mettez sur le
canapé et que vous vous latéralisez
comme ça et bien votre écran va pas
venir pivoter dans la mesure où vous
avez activé la rotation automatique non
il va pas de beauté qu'est-ce qui va se
passer comme il va vous êtes en train de
lire il comprend que vous êtes en train
de lire et il voit que avec le gyroscope
vous tournez parce que vous votre tête
elle tourne également donc il va vous
êtes toujours face au texte vous êtes en
train de lire et bien qu'est-ce qui va
se passer et bien il ne pivotera pas
c'est intelligent et une fois de plus
c'est grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle en gros ce qu'il faut
retenir ici c'est que votre caméra elle
va être en permanence en éveil alors
rassurez-vous c'est pas pour vous
fliquer c'est pas pour venir voir ce qui
se passe chez vous c'est pas le but le
but c'est de venir optimiser un peu les
choses améliorer automatiser pour que
vous n'ayez pas vous prendre la tête
vous prenez le smartphone ça marche
directement simple efficace bien
autre truc intéressant on parle du
Snapdragon secure alors l'idée c'est
quoi c'est comment votre smartphone va
venir se déverrouiller on connaît le
fait déverrouiller avec un schéma avec
un code avec le capteur d'empreintes
digitale et également avec la
reconnaissance du visage en deux
dimensions ici c'est plutôt rare qu'on
trouve de la 3D ça existe mais c'est
plutôt rare ici ils ont développé une
nouvelle façon de venir déverrouiller
son smartphone c'est à dire que vous
allez avoir une détection sur le fait
que vous ne regardez et surtout que vous
êtes vivant vous n'êtes pas endormi
c'est vraiment vous ça veut dire que si
quelqu'un fait une reconstitution en
trois dimensions de votre visage et bien
ça marchera pas parce qu'il faut qu'il y
ait des traits il faut que ça bouge il
faut que ce soit vivant alors il nous
annonce également une détection de la
peau je sais pas trop comment ça va
marcher mais a priori si on le fait avec
un masque de cire ça ne fonctionnera pas
et si on le fait avec une photo qui
imprimante de dimension ça n'est pas
vivant ça ne marchera pas non plus donc
c'est plutôt rassurant en terme de
sécurité si on veut déverrouiller son
smartphone il faut que ce soit vous que
vous le regardiez que vous soyez vivant
et personne ne va pouvoir venir vous
imiter à moins de fabriquer peut-être
super masque je suis même pas sûr que ça
marcherait même pas et c'est quoi le
code nous parle également d'un mode
cinématique qu'on pourrait venir
retrouver pour fabriquer toutes vos
vidéos qui vous permettrait d'avoir
comme notamment sur les iPhone et bien
le fou derrière plan c'est le point est
fait sur vous vous retournez quelqu'un
derrière le point fait sur les personnes
vous revenez le point revient sur vous
bon ça on l'a déjà vu chez Apple mais ça
va arriver également grâce à ce nouveau
processeur sur tous les smartphones
Android en tout cas sur toutes les
marques qui voudront bien l'intégrer
[Musique]
toute la partie graphique le GPU est
géré parce qu'ils appellent l'adréno
c'est leur marque la marque du GPU de
Qualcom ici on va voir une partie
graphique qui va être 25% plus
performant que la génération précédente
toujours un peu cette ordre de grandeur
de toute façon les anciennes générations
versus les nouvelles générations 25 30 %
donc ici on est dans le truc et 45 % de
conservation énergétique mais là où ça
intéressante c'est qu'on va retrouver
tous les formats qui sont cool le HDR
vivid le hdr10 le HDR 10 plus le
dolbivision on a vraiment une très
grosse compatibilité ici et on a
également l'Adaptative HDR sine qualcool
et nous ont montré un truc et super cool
c'est LE RAY tricing je sais pas si ça
vous parle Ray plus loint TR a C ING ça
ça fonctionne vraiment pour les jeux
vidéo et qu'est-ce qui est super
intéressant avec ce ray tracing c'est au
niveau des reflets que vous allez avoir
imaginez vous avez un personnage et
devant vous avez une flaque d'eau et
bien vous avez un reflet ok ça
fonctionne mais là vous avez un truc qui
est vraiment dingue j'ai vu les démos
c'est fou c'est extrêmement bluffant et
surtout sur smartphone ce qui fait que
vous allez avoir un vrai bon reflet vous
allez vraiment voir le reflet du une
superbe colorimétrie un truc qui marche
super bien et ça en termes de
maximisation d'expérience je vois la
flotte tu arrives à côté pour le gaming
croyez-moi c'est pareil et ça ils
annoncent que ça arrivera chez vivo chez
oneplus chez tous les partenaires bien
évidemment sur les smartphones Android
côté audio on a le spatial audio avec le
suivi de la tête le tracking de la tête
lorsque vous bougez la tête et bien le
son bien suivre le mouvement de votre
tête ça c'est chouette aussi donc voilà
un peu pour ce portrait robot de ce que
je fasse gaffe parce que là ça monte et
ça monte vite
ça arrive ça rattrape la vache quand je
vous ai mis un peu de travers ils vont
mettre droit froid et avoir vu une
tortue là-bas mais non c'est un énorme
mal que j'ai l'impression ok on va
essayer par se tromper on va voir juste
où ça monte ok je vais faire vite voilà
un peu pour ce portrait robot il aurait
pour y avoir encore plein de choses à
raconter c'est une question très
technique ces petits processeur graver
en quatre nanomètres je trouve ça super
cool parce que une fois de plus au-delà
du côté technique et ça ça montre les
usages qu'on va avoir sur nos
smartphones l'année prochaine smartphone
Android en 2023 sur le plus haut de
gamme attention je parle vraiment ici du
plus haut de gamme on n'est pas sur le
milieu de gamme ça va être les
smartphones les plus chers ça va être
les flexible soyons clairs là-dessus
donc c'est pas ce qu'on trouvera sur
tous les smartphones Android mais vous
savez quand les innovations elles
arrivent toujours par le haut et ensuite
elles arrivent petit à petit sur le
milieu de gamme et ensuite sur l'entrée
de gamme il faut un peu de temps mais ça
finira par arriver donc ce qu'on voit
ici c'est que ça monte ce qui va arriver
sur le plus haut de gamme en 2023 et
petit à petit les autres années sur le
milieu de gamme je regarde derrière si
je me prends pas une vague en 2024 2025
ici ça donc ça c'est tout ça vachement
chouette alors il pourrait y avoir plein
d'autres choses à venir vous raconter
encore ici mais c'est vraiment un point
qui est très technique si vous voulez
aller plus loin je vous invite à venir
lire les papiers de mes potes
journalistes qui sont plus loin dans
l'analyse vraiment très technique il y a
des gens qui vont extrêmement loin au
niveau de l'analyse c'est pas le but ici
c'est le but c'est de comprendre un peu
ce qui se passe et les usages qu'on va
avoir derrière donc ça je trouve ça
vachement cool alors après ici chez toi
comme eh ben il y a plein d'autres
choses qui sont montrées ils nous
parlent également de Saint dragon
compute 8 CX on parle d'ordinateur ou
pas également d'intelligence
artificielle n'ont pas trop la vague
derrière on nous parle également de
snack dragon cendres on nous parle de
son avec des faibles latence on nous
parle de audio spatialisé on nous parle
de Bluetooth et le on nous parle
également de Xa c'est-à-dire un mélange
un peu entre de la réalité augmentée et
de la réalité mixte on voit on va
pouvoir venir ici et puis on se
concentre vraiment une fois de plus en
restant dragon 8 Jane 2 qui vient
toucher un peu tous les points au niveau
de votre smartphone c'est à dire la
vidéo la photo gaming la performance
automobile à 5G l'affichage audio bref à
360 degrés sur votre smartphone le plus
haut de gamme ne bouge pas trop la
flotte en 2023 dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas dans les commentaires
est-ce que vous avez hâte de venir
découvrir ça et moi je le trouve qui est
vraiment intéressant par rapport aux
autres années qu'on n'avait pas c'est
qu'ici il y a un très gros Focus qui est
fait avec de l'intelligence artificielle
Qualcom bombarde pour arriver avec des
processeurs extrêmement puissants
extrêmement performant pour avoir une
super expérience sur rapide et ça c'est
toi dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en
bas dans les commentaires moi je vais
profiter un peu j'ai encore pas mal de
cours toute la journée j'ai encore
demain un peu je vais profiter on est
aujourd'hui le 16 novembre dans quelques
jours c'est mon anniversaire vous voyez
je me fais plaisir je me fais un beau
cadeau je suis ici ah ouais même si
c'est quelqu'un qui m'invite allez je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
bientôt ciao je vous laisse profiter de
la merde
[Musique]